foreign
11 o'clock we'll start our work session
and I will remind everybody to turn your
mics on uh because we are live streaming
we've got a little ax about that last
week excluding myself so we might kind
of make sure the mics are on uh the
first bill we have up is House Bill 419
relative to
mass learning communities program of the
community college system
and I see Chancellor Rubenstein and
director Reed are here I'm assuming you
want to make a comment or two
or representative lab do you want to
no
um
like sure somebody should be taking
notes
right on the back of one of these well
good call
you got a pen
yeah thank you sir
okay I'm not exactly
okay thank you very much represent
emmerich and members of division uh
division two for the record my name is
Rick Ladd I'm from Haverhill New
Hampshire uh this bill is really timely
um if you look at the sheet I just added
to you I'll try to get through it
quickly I know you have a lot on a dock
today but math learning communities
program as a result of what we've seen
over the last if you look at the first
in the box there are 2012 back when Paul
leather and Jenny Berry were at the
department uh representative Heath is
very familiar with that as she worked
there also prior to that I
um I won't say how much prior
represented Heath but the there was a
committee form a task force look at
mathematics in our state that task force
back then identified that we're not
accomplishing what we should be
accomplishing in mathematics that's 2012
looking at where we are today
we sometimes think well all this is a
result of the pandemic covid-19 it's not
where we have with mathematics we've had
a continual slide going in this day as
terms of our performance and Proficiency
in mathematics
I've highlighted two of those box or
three items down the bottom there New
Hampshire's nape report card October
2022 New Hampshire students test scores
fell during the covet pandemic
continuing a long-term decline
the biggest decline both nationally and
in New Hampshire was in our eighth grade
math according to 2022 s assessments
taken by a sample of students 30 percent
of the state's 8th graders and 40
percent of our fourth graders are
proficient or above in mathematics
48 percent of students proficient in
mathematics in 2019 and you can read on
when I came before a division two years
ago I handed to them a flow chart of
tracking cohorts the same group of
students as their fifth graders 6th
graders 7th graders right through to
high school
in looking at one of those courts and
I'll leave you a copy of this because
this is ancient history however it's
reflective exactly what you if you look
at I platform today which is the data
Pro Center that the doe has for looking
at the same information for example the
fifth grade class in 2010
was at 75 percent proficient in
mathematics sixth grade 71 percent
in the 2012 a seventh grader 67 percent
8th grade 66 percent that's 2013. in
2016 because there's two years we didn't
do the testing there in 11th grade 40
percent proficient it just goes like
this and then we see this real drop
coming out of middle school and going
into High School
and when we looked at this particular
program in front of you today we looked
at uh developing I did this in
conjunction with the community college
system New Hampshire and folks behind me
and Beth Dorian I don't see Beth here
today but we looked at how can we really
change this trend that we have going on
in the state
so we implemented a program called math
learning communities that was a grant
that community college system had
received two hundred thousand dollars
it's a grant that did a lot of good
we at by the time we were in several
years into this grant we had 37 38 high
schools participating across the state
what it does is you can look in the
bottom side of the sheet here you can
see that for example in Algebra 1 is
taken in the 10th grade upon completing
the 10th grade what we got gave to the
students was the Next Generation
accuplacer test that's a test which are
an assessment which has been used to
identify Readiness for going into the
community college system
so we wanted to find out if these
students coming out of 10th grade
algebra 1 are really ready to go ahead
to Algebra 2 trig geometry
calculus
and we found that there was a number of
students that weren't really math ready
they scored like a 63 or lower in the
accuplacer test so what we looked at is
there another way of trying to get the
mass foundations that are necessary into
these youngsters before they graduate
because what we were also seeing that
when they went off to Community College
or post-secondary education primarily
the community college system
we saw that 60 of the students at that
time required what we call remedial
education now we're trying to assist
these students through working in the
class and working at specific holes or
weaknesses but we of that 60 percent
50 percent never got a two-year degree
so we spent a lot of money
and they spent a lot of money
trying to get this degree but they had
this hole they weren't ready for college
level mathematics so what we did at the
end of 10th grade after working with
parent with counselors Math teachers in
the schools we found we we looked at
this next Generation accuplacer test
assessment and determined there were
students which would benefit going from
going a different track to try and get
these skills into them so what this
program did is set a program called math
foundations and then quantitative math
which would be taught in the 12th grade
so math foundations in 11th grade
students went that track and learned the
mathematics through different ways they
applied the mathematics they looked at
the skills that are necessary that
algebra one links with algebra 2 they it
was taught in such a way that it was
Applied Mathematics
upon completing that course and those
students that went on to quantitative
math if they scored on that accuplacer
at a level there was a score that we
were able to identify then and if they
got a C or better
they automatically received the four
credits for college mathematics so they
are ready to go into college and compete
with other students and they already had
that math uh requirement under their
belts and were able to go farther so
what the program is happened is that we
haven't funded the two hundred thousand
dollars that's necessary to keep this
afloat through the community college
system we received materials textbooks
worksheets all that
we also received training in the
summertime this money includes bringing
teachers down from various schools and
having teachers teaching teachers that
have been in this program and with the
assistance of of professional folks out
of the community college system training
these people on how to teach math
foundations and quantitative math
they went back to their schools and we
saw a tremendous success
so and the 200 000 pays for the
transportation down the summertime and
pays for the instruction we're also
receiving from the community college
system Direction and support and
coordination of this program and that
would be through the community college
system and I'm sure they can explain
that to you as they come out
so this is a timely uh bill as I've
mentioned to you because we have this uh
real issue in our state right now and
they're going to see a number of bills
floating at you this year trying to
resolve how we can help raise the bar in
mathematics in the state yeah you can
look at the aggregate scores and yes we
are fourth or fifth highest in the
country on our aggregate scores but
we're not where New Hampshire wants to
be
I just had a bill this morning we were
talking about Proficiency in London area
in Nashua and some of our high schools
you look at the math proficiency scores
and quite frankly it's pretty pathetic
we are not where we need to be and so
what we need to do is get this training
into the folks we have a lot of schools
now are trying to start to correct this
but this is something that's bigger than
that we need to correct it on our state
level we need to find out where the
holes are and remediate those holes and
and you'll see us come forward when and
an individual doe to help us do that so
I I don't want to take any more time I
know you got a busy schedule ahead of
you I will drop off some of this
information which I have on charting the
cohorts as they go through school we've
done it for all these different groups
and the same trend is there at the end
of Middle School our scores take a huge
dive this is one reason why we did
several years ago require four years of
mathematics one year of the math is
embedded you have to have three years to
get out as a minimum
credits to get out of high school but we
require four years one of those courses
in the high school has to be embedded or
take the fourth year mathematics
embedding math skills into social
studies using spreadsheets knowing how
to make a spreadsheet using it in
science that's embedded math that has to
be approved by your local school board
thank you
questions Pete
thank you Mr chair is there a gender
difference
a gender difference
yeah
when I was a school principal back in
Maine years ago and I ended up my
Administration all that elsewhere
but we did a study up in arusta County
Presque Isle Caribou area Limestone when
there was an air base up there
we took the girls and put them for
mathematics in one class we put the boys
over there all the social stuff
disappeared we did see growth on the
part of both groups
so then it was decided that well
spreading them apart is not really the
answers the answer is try to stop all
that social stuff from going on and and
uh that's tough to do when you're in
high school
um I've been there uh so I I'm I'm not
going to answer your questions all the
way but uh I think that you're you're
you might ask the community college
system behind me are they saying you
know
gender related to what they're seeing up
there I don't know I don't have the
answer on that one I'm not going to go
there either well I guess I was asking
your data that you're collecting doesn't
track gender no my the data that we're
tracking is aggregate of the school if
it's more than 10 students at a grade
level of course and and uh and uh
thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative Ladd
um so what the question I wanted to ask
you I think you answered it but where'd
you come up with the 200 000 it seems
like now I I think I heard you say now
that you're just replacing the original
Grant
yes and that was the original Grant of
200 000 and what we have is we have
people already a community college
system are well trained on delivering
um the the materials are I I've seen all
those materials they're easily run off
um with a copy machine or and those are
available and what I've been told by the
community college system that this will
make this program work remember we do
have 37 38 high schools which had
started that program so those a lot of
those materials and training is already
there and we're going to use people that
are trained in this to train others so
there should be some reduction in costs
that way
thank you Mr chairman nice to see you
again miss uh president uh
representative glad matter of fact I
experienced Limestone and lowering I
know he did Mr Air Force so hey it's uh
it was a good experience
uh matter of fact that's where we first
started our married life
uh how much effect do you think
the systems like everyday math like
lattice
uh Common Core all these
I I don't know if I'd I'd uh
put it on that I had a meeting with Math
teachers in the Rivendell School
District not more in about a month and a
half two months ago Rivendell is the
interstate District we have Orford and
Fairley Vermont
and I met with all the math teachers at
the high school middle Elementary and
um High School
I think that there is
an issue that we need to address locally
as well are Math teachers talking with
Math teachers at different levels
oftentimes the elementary kids in in
Fairly are taught all our New Hampshire
kids go over to Vermont for elementary
school the high school middle schools on
the Orford Side in New Hampshire do we
get together and really discuss K
through 12 and coordinate our curriculum
and our instruction and are we all
seeing instruction the same when I met
with those folks there was questions
half of them felt we have to really go
after the multiplication tables
memorization the other half saying well
maybe we ought to just talk teach them
how it works the principles behind it so
if we're split in terms of you know how
to teach and so in in the in my district
up in Haverhill SAU 23 right now they're
looking at their their curriculum right
now and think about overhauling the
whole thing
um that's good however it may be costly
as well this is why we need to have the
analyst there at the Department of
Education it's going to help us do that
deep dive maybe there's only holes in
our current math program we can clamp
the holes and save money and also
increase our proficiency so I would say
much of this I believe is at the local
level I wouldn't lay it on Common Core I
wouldn't lay it on because we all
believe we all believe kids have to be
competent
Common Core was made up of competencies
and so what we got to look at and make
sure those competencies are being taught
at the level that we're testing
and and that's another issue matching up
our assessment to our curriculum looking
at our standards do our standards
parallel at the grade levels at the
state to what our grade levels are doing
sometimes you can have an assessment
test and it's testing for example it
could be social studies U.S history we
teach U.S history at what grade level
another school at another grade level if
you test at that one grade level earlier
the one that hasn't had it yet is
obviously going to have low assessment
scores
so one of the keys is that we get on
board with our Assessment program and
know what we're assessing and align it
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative for taking the questions
I really should start by apologizing for
inadvertently uh sending the education
committee an email I intended for the
election committee I got my bills mixed
up so sorry for that little bit of spam
still a good video but not meant for you
my apologies my question is since I'm a
freshman could you help me understand a
bit more why you know this program is
valuable in terms of you know why is the
Community College needed to assist the
high schools you know deliver on their
math curriculum because you know
obviously there are more experienced
people here but I would I could really
use a bit of that background well the
community college system as well as the
university system have the folks which
are training our teachers for one
um in looking at this they have the
capability of coordinating uh rather
than having let's say the department do
it uh we're working with career Pathways
and certification that's offered through
the community college system which is
oftentimes linked through our concurrent
and dual enrollment programs which are
taught in the high school there's a lot
of interaction now between the community
college system and high schools and I
hope it goes down to Middle Schools as
well so in in in that regard I think
that the to use and they have the staff
available to work with our high school
teachers
we have now some in fact a number we're
seeing we're seeing gains going forward
especially when we look at our
concurrent dual enrollment program
participation is going up however here
is an opportunities for us to use that
expertise that wisdom that the community
college has in in saying here's some of
the holes we are seeing when we are
receiving these students in the high
school from the high schools we have
oftentimes thought it was a community
college system you fix this
but after we discussed on the education
committee for years it's not the
community college's problem
it's our K-12 issue we're sending the
kids to them in a remedial fashion and
so they're saying here's the holes we
see we can work with you I think it's
great we should look at education not as
K-12 but k-16 quick quick follow-up
and this is strictly a voluntary program
where high schools can choose to you
know take the help or not yes thank you
sir
the way we teach teachers is that a
problem is that the problem
in other words the teachers colleges
I mean we are from your from your
assessment
we have a teacher shortage committee
going on right now I'm on that there's a
lot of different variables which are
coming into why we have that teacher
shortage
um and it has to do also with the the
shortage areas which we're seeing are
science
math special education technology those
are the shortage areas
mathematics has always been a shortage
area
um so uh
how are teaching mathematics in the
maybe they need more math there I don't
know at that level maybe they need less
gen Ed and more skill oriented subjects
at that wonderful article in the Wall
Street Journal this last weekend on why
we have four-year degrees maybe we only
need three take all the Gen Ed stuff out
and teach the skills kids need
thank you Mr chair thank you
um this program is wonderful and I think
that every kind of refresher or anything
we can do to help our students
um renew their interest in mathematics
is another way to build their
mathematics kids all learn in different
levels at different paces and for so
many students they forget
what they've learned and I think this is
a way to catch them up especially before
they go into the Community College it's
a wonderful program I'm really
disappointed that in fact we haven't
funded this consistently I remember very
well when Paul leather and I worked with
the Community College about the level of
mathematics at the community college and
we were really concerned so I I hope
that we decide to retain this for
consideration for the budget you know I
hope so too the when I was working with
General Barrette he was the AG over the
National Guard here he and I both went
to OCS Army and uh when I was talking
with him when we took our Howitzer
batteries in the state here and put them
into more of a missile oriented we
shared our our Battalion with West
Virginia and New Hampshire went in the
same unit he told me the folks we want
to hire folks from New Hampshire not
West Virginia because the New Hampshire
kids are thinkers they're have good
professional work skills but they all
all have this innate ability to do the
mathematics we need we just need to keep
it there but we are strong our kids are
ready for this and we shouldn't leave
any of these youngsters behind
especially when we have this alternative
way of really ensuring that it's taught
the way they learn matching learning
thank you Mr chair thank you
representative lad I think I just have a
quick follow-up question to make sure I
heard you correctly
um I think when you are speaking about
your um little handout here that at one
point you said the two hundred thousand
dollars would cover both transportation
and instruction
did I think that's for the training
program in the summertime they so it
takes care they get a mild reimbursement
similar to what we receive as
thank you representative
so in in North Conway um the community
college is going to is going to uh
eliminate their overhead with their
physical brick and mortar
um school that they're using right now
and and move the programs into the
Kennett High School and just recently
president president Lloyd made a
presentation to the Local School Board
and and he started out by saying we have
these programs and how do we attract
people to to the programs but then they
turned it around and rethought it and
said why don't we bring the programs to
where the kids are so bringing all their
um
they're dual and concurrent and and
they're running stock programs it and by
the way a much discounted price 150 per
cost
and also uh
um get building up their college credits
while they're still in high school
and by by merging with by bringing the
community college and merging it with
with the high school
and that's a good move forward that's
what has to be done elsewhere in the
state as well thank you
any other questions
okay thank you representative thank you
does anyone else want to speak on this
bill
Dr Chancellor good morning Mark
Rubinstein from the community college
system I'll just speak briefly to
reinforce what representative Ladd
shared we've been doing a little bit of
background work since representative
land brought this back to the table
we've looked across the community
college system to identify colleagues
who've been working on this project when
it was first initiated we've done some
Outreach to identify Educators in
secondary schools who'd be interested
partners for this starting to take a
look at curriculum to figure out the
courses so we're prepared to support
this if the legislature chooses to
reinvest
any questions for the chancellor
which I knew a Dream It's Made by Joe
seconded by Mary all those in favor just
raise your hand we won't call the roll
okay unanimous for the record
okay I think we'll close a discussion on
uh house uh House Bill 419 and we'll
move to house bill 420.
has to do with the Dual concur
enrollment
representative Ladd you have a comment
well thank you once again uh for the
record Rick Ladd here from New Hampshire
uh the due on concurrent enrollment
program is one which uh when we we
started this program
oh how many years ago
um I would say
2017 they're roughly or 18.
um this is a program and representative
Buco just referenced that you know 150
bucks for a course right now while
you're in in the high school first
waiting until after you graduate from
high school to take that same course 150
bucks for the course but after high
school if you're going to do it at the
community college system it would cost
you close to what thirteen hundred
dollars
so just think of that savings that if a
student could get this done while
they're in grades 10 11 or 12. what the
bill before you does we are now
extending this program to grade 10.
Beyond 11 and 12 which we're already
doing it we're also opening it up to
rather than two courses per year one can
take up to five courses per year
and we're also extending it to courses
that are not just stem courses Science
Tech engineering and Mathematics
after discussions with Folks at the
community
CTE centers Career Technical Education
Centers and people in the classrooms uh
throughout the state and high school
we've learned that there are a lot of
writing skills that a person needs in
order to communicate
both you know thinking skills and logic
skills and rhetoric and these are taught
not necessarily always through this stem
course
there's a number of other courses which
we want students to take while they're
in high school which are not stem simply
because it motivates them that I can
take I can go to higher education I can
make it and my own daughter did this
years ago in another state in Alaska
where she took some courses in child
care while she was in high school and
got college credits from UAA uaf
University Alaska Fairbanks for that
while she was also getting credit the
same time for graduating from high
school they did this way before we did
it
she took these courses and found out she
can do it now she's a speech pathologist
down at Pawleys Island South Carolina
and having a wonderful career it was the
start and those credits were accepted by
Elmira College on her bachelor's level
and then accepted later when she went to
University of South Carolina med school
to get the Audiology degree
so this program allows students to
receive college credit at the same time
they're getting high school credit they
can take the course in the high school
the high school teacher who's teaching
this course
has to meet all the standards of a
professor at the community college
system New Hampshire you're going to
have two of your Masters you're going to
have to have uh meet all those criteria
that are so that are necessary to be a
teacher or professor at the community
college system so the standards aren't
lessened any they're same standards
while the course is being taken but what
it does do it allows students to start
taking these courses
early on in their High School careers we
have some students now that are
graduating from high school believe it
or not they have close to one whole year
of college credit already under their
belts and that is transferable into the
community college system and after we
work with the community college system
and the university system last year and
trying to ensure that these are
transferable between the community
college system and the the community
college system and the university system
where I have 30 different degrees which
that is being done in right now we're
seeing the system working together High
School Community College and the
university system and trying to
ease the burden of this debt that
students we have not what the second or
the highest college level debt in the
country here in New Hampshire
we can avoid that and when we initiated
this bill back in 17 we were only paying
in this program uh 850 000 in the first
year and then FY 19 950 000 it's since
grown now to its 1.5 million dollars per
year and this bill is asking we go to
3.25
million per year by doing this you're
saving up in a double digit
figures Millions dollars for our
students later on if they had to take
all these courses later on
so it's saving debt at the same time
it's raising the bar while we're in high
school and that that is needed so I will
stop there I do have a hand I can make
copies for you get that to you as well
as I did in the first one I'll get all
this to you for the record
okay questions Tom
thank you so if I understand this
program this provides the tuition for
um five courses and if they if a student
wants to take more than that they can
they can pay for it on their own it's
out of their own pocket yes but but it
does provide the tuition for up to five
up to five which is a really a
tremendous gain
for those students it certainly is thank
you
thank you uh
you mentioned competencies before
why should we have a line between
community college and high school
if you're competent in something doesn't
make any difference when you get that
knowledge
and to fill a matrix
it would seem so you would you would
eliminate that line of or or have the
competency at a level say at the college
level
or on a subject
what do you feel about that
I'm having a hard time tracking what
you're asking well you said competency
yeah okay your competency in English so
say okay you and have to develop a
standard
and meet that standard once you meet
that standard it doesn't make any
difference when you meet that standard
as long as you meet that standard
because that way even though an eighth
grader could uh if if if you write the
standard correctly
it would it would work it seemed to me
it would work it I you know like I I
took physics in high school
and the the person teaching it knew was
subject well but he couldn't get it into
this head
I took the same subject
in at the community college level
and he was a previous engineer civil uh
mechanical engineer it's at uh General
Electric and you know I could follow him
and I I got an A I mean you know it's if
they if the delivery isn't you know on
you what how you learn it's I mean
that's a big problem it comes down to
teaching style and learning style
and there are some of you that are very
auditory some they're very tactile
physical type stuff in learning when I
and there's other methods too when I
took trigonometry I could regurgitate
everything in it where I really learned
trig is when I was dropped out of a huey
in Vietnam with my aiming sticks and all
that and triangulation and surveying
trying to figure out where we're going
to put that battery coming in I learned
how to do that real quickly and it made
sense because I was actually doing it I
wanted to get out of there and so
um I guess there's many students like
myself that have a hard time reading
this and say okay I like to have to I
like to do it as for I learn as I do
and just like in your carpentry you
learn from your mistakes well I so
there's it goes on the teaching style
learning style if you have a teacher
that's not on the same page as far as
how you learn you're going to have a
tough time that's that happens right
down in first grade second grade right
well to you know to follow up with what
you just said in that physics uh example
I I love to hunt at the time especially
then
and uh he would the example was trig
and using a trig to shoot a deer how
many feet would you have to lead the
deer if you knew how fast the deer was
going across your field of view I mean
and I mean that that fits right in and
then and what what I developed here was
a loaf of trick because there's a lot of
things you can do with trig that in
other parts of your life
I mean it it was just amazing what uh
you know what what he could get into
thank you Mr chair
I think we all agree the merits of the
dual enrollment program are excellent I
I'd like to I think we all like it a lot
because we've talked about it multiple
times I I'd like to move forward and
me too yeah but um
thank you um it's a great program and
thank you for expanding it um to you
know thinking skills and the writing
skills I that's wonderful but can you
give me a narrative of so this money
goes to the Community College
um if you didn't have this money would
there be courses not offered in the high
school in this program I understand that
it's going for tuition but where I have
a gap of my understanding is if you
didn't have this would those there not
be courses in the high school that that
do this do you understand what I'm
saying you you this program of course
you have running start early college you
can a high school student can also do
this at the college location where you
can take a course there and get credit
this you know the same way it will cost
you a little bit more but it can be done
right there and we have students are
doing that that's where you know and I
want to thank very much Shannon and mark
behind me the community college has been
a real proponent and leader in working
with public K-12 education and they
deserve that recognition for delving
down and helping us not just there but
with Career Tech as well
and so it's inspiring to see programs
like this this was you know I I've been
talking I talked with them often about
this program but this proposal is coming
out of them saying that we we can really
get more kids into this program we can
strengthen this program and help save
that debt that they're incurring later
on and that's a critical component of
this program just do the mathematics
figure and you're good at that because
that's your job here in finance but look
at what what would it cost a student to
take these courses not as running start
or early East or early college
what what would it cost later after that
you know High School graduation
you would see it in the millions of
dollars
and as so this is a tremendous
opportunity that we should not you know
lose the money here is a definite
you find me
thank you Mr chair and again thank you
for taking the questions
I am um looking at the bill language and
obviously we understand the intent
between behind you know increasing the
cap but I'm not sure I understand and
I'm actually very concerned about the
language that removes the requirement
that those be stem classes because to me
what made this program very effective is
that it was focused on you know
expertise that we agree the state is in
dire need and we need more students
trained in the fact that we remove that
seems to lose that focus and I'm just
trying to understand the intent behind
that and how do you feel that would
benefit you know the uh
State versus having left that in while
still increasing the cap I think I think
part of that question should be asked of
Dr Rubin staying behind me the
chancellor but I can tell you that when
I've spoken with the directors of Career
Tech education throughout this state
there is such thing they call soft
skills
you have the skills very specific to the
trade that they're learning
but if they don't have the skills and
how to communicate
and interpret things and fill out an
invoice and and do other other
components of the job which are above
and beyond knowing how to operate the
machine press or the Die Cast material
that that is where this is opening it up
to that side the Slate so we can get to
communication skills as an opportunity
to uh be used to get credit for that
type of training that you absolutely
have to have to be successful in any
career
thank you and just a quick follow-up no
disagreement on the soft skills
I've taught for a living and trust me
the teaching part is way harder than the
understanding the technical side and
I've rubbed elbows with a lot of Geeks
and people who really had a hard time
functioning outside of their you know
happy place but while those particular
skills are indeed necessary this one
doesn't just expand that into soft
skills it basically gives a carte
blanche for any class of any kind and
again you know I would be comfortable
with expanding from stem to include
other things but just a broad you know
removal of that Focus
these courses have to be approved by the
community college system
so so then you're you're really
and as I alluded to earlier in my
presentation
there when we
when we introduce sat as as what we're
going to use in the 11th grade for
determining whether they're meeting our
Statewide proficiencies at that level
that was first started in Maine
and when Maine gave the s.a.t they all
sudden found there's a number of
students that were not planning on going
on to college a number of students that
I can never be successful and they were
getting scores well above 500 600.
I can do it and so that's another thing
with getting into these type other
courses they can learn I can do it and
then you also then get involved with the
the stem area yes I I'm a proponent of
stem but I'm also a proponent that we
need to offer the opportunity for
students to get engaged in in in various
restaurant type courses
Etc that they will then go in different
and then maybe get into the chemistry
Dr no but I I think the next one you got
coming up is 5 42.
542.
establishing academic research and
Improvement performance data analyst
okay representative land thank you
this is a a program which has been
communicated with and put forth by the
Department of Education
we have a department of one over there
when we're looking at our Statewide
assessment which we give to students
in the grades three through eight and
then grade 11. and what we have and yes
you can look on the web and you can get
the aggregate scores you know the the
scores for your state the scores for
your school
but does it really give the the down in
the weeds detail information that is
needed for the individual schools to
really assess and determine where their
strengths and weaknesses are in their
curriculum
do these local school districts and we
have many many small districts Mary
knows has represented Heath knows as a
result of being a commissioner At Doe
that many of these smaller districts
have minimal staff they may have
Administration that's tied up of a
superintendent part-time superintendent
and they may have somebody in charge of
special education but that's where it
stops there's nobody there in curriculum
development
so how do we dig down and find out where
our holes are in meeting with Dr Greene
over at the Department of Education
and with Caitlyn Davis
that it's been determined that for us to
really do the Deep dive we need into
these scores we need a data analysis
analysis over there somebody that's
going to be able to get down and measure
student progress evaluate program
instructional effect of this guide
curriculum development resource
allocations and promote accountability
um that's collect you so we're going to
be collecting this data analyzing the
data reporting the data using that data
for school Improvement mathematics
communicating through this information
we're talking about a position here
that's about a hundred and sixty
thousand dollars first year then it's
you'll see less in the request for the
second year of the biennium 145
000 seeing many of these startup needs
the equipment all is already there so
that that's why they have a lighter a
little lighter cost there in fy25 this
person is absolutely needed for us to
really maximize our use of this
information which we're having which
we're not doing right now when I've
asked asked over the years and
representative Weiler and I have both
asked the same information where we're
looking for accountability
we just haven't been able to get the
information
one person over there can't provide the
information how many times have we asked
the department to really give us some
specific information data regarding
these tests and where kids are and what
we have to do
it's just not there
tracking the cohorts back in 17 18 19 20
I did that I tore those instrument those
tests apart and and we looked at that
but that didn't go far enough it didn't
say where do we have to help in
mathematics
this is what we need right here if we
really want to improve mathematics in
the state if we really want to improve
reading in this state we're going to
have to have more information we're
going to have to do a better diagnosis
of where we are in these tests not just
doing the here's your end result here's
where we are and now we're going to
lower the bar so we're all proficient
then cut it
so if we want to improve we're going to
have to give that resource to the
department to do that when I first came
on board here years ago there were
curriculum people at the department
is there anybody there now in curriculum
and curriculum development the answer is
no
yet we want to have all these Statewide
we have responsibilities A legislature
to set these standards we have to review
the minimum standards for public school
approval that's a responsibility state
board but they can't do that unless it's
approved by legislative oversight
do we have the information to really do
a good job in oversight
I don't think so
and so what we have to do is in working
with them over there they're proposing
this this is a need this is a priority
of the department to have this data anal
analyst over there to help interpret
this and work with districts and helping
them interpret their scores as well
all right
thank you Mr chair thank you um
cheerlead I have um
found it very disheartening quite
frankly that the department has
eliminated so many different well I
don't know if I don't know if it's us in
the finance committee that's eliminated
so many positions but I know that when I
was Deputy Commissioner I had four
content area people and I had um someone
who did the data analysis and those
people not only did that work at the
state level but then they went out to
school districts worked with school
districts held various amounts of of
workshops and and trainings to build the
skills that children need I think was a
big loss for our state so indeed I am
all for this I actually would like to
see us go back to more curriculum area
people as well but um I would like to
absolutely
um support this bill and I know this
bipartisan effort and and certainly
Caitlin Davis needs a lot more help
thank you absolutely thank you thank you
Mr
foreign
thank you
career development of teachers what are
we doing there are we doing are we going
too much on the social side I mean we're
if you have to recertify you know over
time teachers that is
I mean where are we going
I mean it seems so
something's not working here it's it's
for a skew and it's
I just don't I I don't have the answer
maybe uh I know you've been around this
uh we well we've been around this for a
while now
and it's uh it seems so we we keep
rehashing the same thing have tons of
development you know career development
in within the schools I know that for
sure
being a uh
on a school board and it just but it's
not getting anywhere the standards
should be going much higher
I think we've got to get back on the
bill Joe no well no but this is this is
about the bill I mean what what are we
doing I mean we need somebody to analyze
the data that's true now we're back on
the bill
why I mean the question is why why are
the standards bad and are we not
represent Petrie I'd be glad to talk to
thank you Mr chair and again thank you
chairman lad
I'm trying to understand
why is this something that requires a
new position rather than something the
doe could potentially do with existing
staff I mean I'm just again
new to everything so I would really
appreciate a bit of background on what
prevents the department right now from
performing this which would require a
new person to be hired we have one
person over in the department to do all
the state right now Nate green
got a doctor in this subject area he's
probably the top-notch person you're
going to find in this state to do what
he's doing
exceptional uh uh understanding of all
this
to really do this correctly though he
does need that support if we are going
to want to have that data provided to us
if we as legislatures are coming forth
and saying well an extraordinary needs
Grant we need some accountability okay
how are we going to measure that
accountability and what are we going to
use to do that will we be using
information At Doe provides us
I you know it depends on how we set that
up but I
I've seen it that we have never had the
information we need yes we've had
surfacy stuff
but we've never gotten down when I would
say an administrator principal uh
teacher in the classroom we used to try
to analyze our data and we did back then
but that was a different state where I
was and we take our reading scores we
look at throw vocabulary we look at
comprehension we look at all the
specific skills and try to dig down and
find out is it the program or is it the
certain skills which aren't being taught
that's the type of thing we're going to
find out from this extra help here
leaving it just innate to do what we're
going to struggle we if as the education
committees looked at policy and we
consider that we've been looking for
data to be up on the I platform and it's
gradually getting there the I platform
it looks at res if you want to research
these scores you can go do that now
um we would have been able to do that
much earlier and in more depths once we
if we'd had this person and in the
future we will be able to much more uh
in a deeper level and better understand
the direction we have to really go in
um I've seen it now for 14 years it's
time to really give that support over to
the department a a department of one
person
is not enough to analyze data for a
hundred and sixty something thousand
students
and we've got trained people out in the
field to be able to do that as well
um so there's a lot to this job the job
description is going to be a very
difficult one to fill because we're
looking for really talented people up in
town and person to do this
I'll entertain a motion
motion to reach here to retain Mr chair
okay
second by representative Petrie
culture made by representative P all
right all those in favor
unanimous okay thank you representative
Vlad
well now we'll move on to house bill
560.
establishing a contact person
notification program to assist law
enforcement
is there anyone here that would wants to
well I think because it has the dollars
in it
will go down the same path so I'd
okay
I should say um I
I have motion to retain motion to
retained by Mary seconded by Kate
all those in favor
all right I'm assuming somebody's going
hey we'll have somebody new
representative Ladd House Bill
the extraordinary and hates grant for
the record Rick Ladd Haverhill New
Hampshire
um
this is
um you heard the governor's presentation
the other day we're taking everything on
the left base adequacy the four areas to
differentiated Aid then we're looking at
the right hand side of that formula
which is complicated and and
repetitive in many areas look at the
type of Grants we've had we've had
physical capacity disparity Aid the
relief grade the extraordinary needs
Grant Aid which uh Senator Aaron
Hennessy put forth last year in SB 420.
that came to the committee the education
committee for policy we've added in an
accountability portion to that where in
that accountability portion came out of
the recommendations out of the task
force in 2018
on on looking at extraordinary needs the
recommendations for having some
accountability for Grant monies it also
came out of the back in 2008 2009 when
Senator Estabrook was developing the
education funding formula which if we
had funded it properly we probably
wouldn't be where we are today but that
also had an accountability measure
within it as well so within the
extraordinary needs Grant you're looking
at right now that's just one small
component
of what is going to come your way this
year turn regarding education funding
you're going to see HB 540 come to you
which is another area differentiated Aid
which adds a weighted component into
that formula as do over 40 States within
this country we just have one amount of
money for differentiated Aid right now A
little over two thousand dollars that
weighted formula would you know be at
three tiers and we'll explain that when
that 540 comes but that could jump the
budget by another 10 to 20 million
dollars it's not an early bill but it is
an early bill it's one that they did not
Mark as early but there certainly is a
huge fiscal note to that that bill but
this one right here the extraordinary
needs Grant is one where we need to
pursue this and my suggestion is to to
look seriously at what the governor
presented a whittling down stabilization
we need to have
if it was my druthers we wouldn't have
stabilization in that budget that 150
million dollars as a result of a budget
or a funding formula that doesn't work
stabilization was initially put forward
as a support for hold harmless in 2008
nine when Senator Estabrook had it to
hold harmless totaled about 27 million
that was it
then we've gradually tinkered with that
and tinkered with it we took out the
fiscal capacities severity Aid we took
out the monies which are available for
free and reduced if you had a high
percentage of free and reduced kids in
your District which is like over 48
we're talking about a Manchester now
where they would receive twice the base
adequacy that was all taken out and we
put that 156 million dollars into
stabilization
what the governor is proposing is we
Whittle down the stabilization at the
same time grow extraordinary needs
grants and that is going to be a real
trick to do because there's going to be
some that during this growing period may
not receive but we can't continue to
fund ghost kids so uh what we are here
with the extraordinary needs Grant
where that what we added in in policy
was simply putting in an accountability
measure for the extraordinary needs
grant that will require discussion I
understand that but it's just part of
the larger package which is coming at
you in terms of Base adequacy the
governor jumped that by a thousand
dollars per pupil looking at the
differentiated Aid that was also jumped
by the governor in one of those areas
and then and then the uh at the areas on
the right hand side of the formula which
we need to really correct and work on
um I would say as I see it this is
probably close to one of our number one
priorities in education to fix this
and how we fund education
we have a lot of other important needs
we looked at some today but this is
absolutely critical right here for the
questions
thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative Vlad I um have to admit
that I am really unfamiliar with um sub
paragraph D of the bill
um when it comes to
um speaking about
unrestricted adequacy funding
is is there any way you could kind of
adequacy funding base adequacy and the
four areas of differentiate Aid English
language arts free and reduced
remedial reading and special education
those areas I just mentioned are part of
the adequacy formula none of that is
restricted for specific use it's you for
um as a superintendent you use and
School Board use it as you feel
appropriate to provide the opportunity
for an adequate education beyond that we
start getting into areas which include
the grants
those grants are above and beyond and
you can allocate those resources towards
specific areas what we're trying to do
though with this one right here
in extraordinary needs Grant we passed
legislation last year where there is an
accountability measure but we found out
if a district is receiving less than
fifty thousand dollars and we have a
number of districts in that
extraordinary needs Grant we're only
receiving maybe a couple thousand three
thousand dollars
to have them go through all these hoops
of trying to
bring somebody in to look at how we're
using it trying to identify where we're
showing growth or not showing growth
submit the paperwork and all that or now
online to somebody in doe they're saying
you can keep your two or three thousand
dollars we don't have the staff to do
that it's costing us more to prepare the
report that you want than we're
receiving in the grant so the report
came back from the Department of
Education let's have all those that are
receiving less than fifty thousand
dollars not having to submit that
accountability plan and the other
thought was to make all this money not
restricted to unrestrict this money so
it can be used where that District sees
fit years ago when we had fiscal
capacity disparity Aid that was all
unrestricted Monies
you could use it where you felt it was
necessary to improve your education
foreign
thank you thank you Mr chair a quick
follow-up to this
I was thinking that obviously 50 000 is
a reasonably high threshold for
eliminating reporting I mean
wouldn't be wouldn't it be fair to say
that for a district that receives
limited amounts say that five thousand
dollars or ballpark that we were talking
about that the reporting should be very
simple and they shouldn't need all that
expertise I mean couldn't we just change
the you know reporting needs so
everybody can report without being
overly burdened but still have some
accountability data
as we work on this extraordinary needs
Grant the extraordinary needs Grant I'm
just working on my head right now that
was right around 14 point
9 14.2 million dollars it goes down to
nine point something in the second year
of the biennium
we're not talking a significant Dollar
in terms of the whole funding formula as
we move along and we try to consolidate
and it's something that I as a committee
would start to look at do we need to
have a relief Grant
do we need to have a extraordinary needs
Grant do we need fiscal capacity
disparity Aid when they're all based off
of f and R or they're based upon
equalized property valuation per pupil
should we have one Grant to simplify
then if you're going to have more money
in that Grant the 50 000 you might find
as a threshold that most districts are
going to receive a lot more than that
depends upon you know where you go with
this funding formula so rather than
messing with it as a policy committee
right now we took the recommendation of
doe but knowing that probably
extraordinary needs Grant will somewhere
in the future here it will grow and that
might be the singular grant that we have
thank you and my original question
because this was a follow-up
um in regards to the stabilization uh I
Aid you said that you are not happy with
it what would your personal thoughts be
you know as one voice in the State House
on how should we handle it stabilization
we've tried a lot of different
methodologies for reducing enough I
think some of you might remember the
four percent deduct each year and at one
point we even capped it
um which we then had a lawsuit from I
won't say the little that the big towns
on the southern part of the state on the
ocean and we lost that lawsuit
um and uh the four percent is since gone
because it was not done in this
graduated uh it was had the waterfall
effect when you went over the cliff you
lost significant dollars and of course
it's all based upon the previous year
and we saw school districts unable to
plan and their resources properly so
um this this process of stabilization is
something that as a result we have a
formula that really
um
foreign
we're not taking in account the loss of
demographic in the state
we're funding students that maybe don't
exist I know and a program that once was
um but we also have inflation going on
and we as legislature keeps saying you
gotta do more
and and oftentimes not funding it
special education it's fed said 40
percent we're down what 16 percent uh
revenue from them and we're having to
pick up the difference there too now so
um stabilization needs to go that was a
recommendation that came out of the
I was the one but I supported the
reduction of the stabilization it came
out of the umberger study back in 2018
get rid of stabilization
direct the money where it needs to be
directed
well I entertained a motion to retain
motion to retain thank you Mary do we
have a second second by Dan okay all
those in favor
foreign
I think that
foreign okay being one o'clock it's time
you have to excuse me I do have a little
bit of a lingering cold so I had to just
get some
water here
um we do have
um a presentation to kind of walk you
through the kind of gets even overview
of our uh budget and um
what uh priorities so the people are
watching could you introduce yourselves
please oh I'm sorry
um good afternoon thank you for allowing
us to address the committee I'm William
Cass Department of uh Transportation
commissioner with me is Andre Brier he's
our Deputy Commissioner later on in the
discussion I'm going to ask Dave
rodrigue my assistant commissioner to
come up and talk on some of the elements
of the department that are under his
purview
so
um
thank you so we do have a presentation
and some information to go over that
summarizes our our budget and then we
can answer whatever questions you you
have
um also
um
when we had done the previous overview
and presentation of the department we
had left you what with a with a book
given an overview of the department and
the agency
um budget presentation we've updated
that book for you all that has
um
uh
um accounting unit by accounting unit a
summary of what the accomplishments are
what they do and then the summary of um
you know what the agency's efficiency
budget was request was in the governor's
request so it's all summarized in a
accounting unit by accounting unit uh
fashion
but for today what I'd like to do is
Step you through the presentation that
we had put together
um and I hope I'll answer most of your
questions about our budget to start off
with
um a very quick uh recap from our
previous presentation of the
Department's Mission Transportation
excellence and enhancing the quality of
life in New Hampshire
um I won't go through them all again but
those are just a reminder some of the
key facts of the size and scope of the
department Statewide
1650 permanent employees
59 Bridges
um
and about 4 600 miles of roadway that
um on slide four is a funding summary of
our foi 22 actual expenditures
so the actual expenditures for FY 22 are
587 million all told for the Department
as I've explained previously we tend to
break things up uh into two major parts
of our
budget the municipal Aid and
construction portion which is a lot of
pass-through funds a lot of our
construction program
um that was about
um 52 of our actual expenditures in FY
22 or 305 million dollars
and the pied in Orange which is our
operating budget
um which are the operating costs uh for
people to work at the department do the
jobs that they do uh the actual
expenditures FY 22 or 282 million
dollars or 48 of our budget
and again just a summary at the bottom
our budget is comprised of
multiple funding sources uh in the rough
percentages there the highway fund
federal funds Turnpike funds other funds
and a very small percentage of General
on
slide or page five and Page Six are a
summary of a comparison very high level
comparison of the FY 22 budget
Appropriations compared to the FY 23
fy23
adjusted authorized
and then on page six getting to the
heart of the matter is the fy24
governor's recommended budget and the
fy25 governor's recommended budget so
you have those all laid out there for
comparison but fy24
the governor's recommended budget is
about 757 million dollars
um
and um again in the two parts of the
budget that we talk about Municipal Aid
and construction funds of 415 million
dollars or both
55 percent of that budget and the
operating budget is about
um
342 million dollars of 45 of that budget
but I'd like to draw your attention to
um
when you compare say
um you know the FY 23 adjusted
authorized to the fy24 governance budget
and FY 25 budget is that the operating
costs are very flat
um but that was the budget targets we
were given those are the budget targets
we had met we had met Municipal Aid and
construction fluctuates a little bit
with with the amount of federal funds
and things that that we get but the
operating budgets and the operating
costs I want to just draw your attention
to those comparisons
um very flat
um with some very minor
on page um on page seven of our of this
presentation
um
gives a summary of the
um budget in a different format and a
bar chart that again compares the 22
actual 23 adjusted authorized the 24
agency and 24 Governors budget and the
25 agency in 25 governance budget
um and it Compares them by the mix of
fundings that we have uh in there with
the turnpike funds on top Highway funds
uh the maroonish color in the middle
General funds is a very very thin sliver
of about uh
quarter of a percent of our budget in
there and uh then other funds in the
federal funds that go in to comprise so
that gives a very
high level snapshot of the funding
makeup of our budget request here
and on page 8 is just a summary of um
over time of the dots
um
authorized full-time positions
so you'll notice that going back uh
roughly 10 years
through several budgets through
um
2011 through 2014
there were a number of positions as we
Consolidated some Patrol sheds and tried
to balance the budget by eliminating a
number of positions and since 2014 we've
been very flat at about that 1650
positions and continue
um and I point that out compared to the
next slide slide nine which Compares
those number of full-time positions
with
um the vehicle miles traveled over time
and how they and how the vehicle miles
have have increased
so
um
you can see the red line which is the
amount of traffic volume that's using
the roadways you see that dip in 2019
which was due to covid and how it's
rebounding but essentially what I like
to to point out with this this
um
slide is that I think the Department of
Transportation is an efficient
organization we have shown that uh you
know we have continued to do more with
less
this chart does not reflect the current
vacancy rate that we are experiencing of
around 20 to 25 vacancy rates
um but we continue to
um meet our mission
um despite that back so I like to point
this out because I do believe that dot
has shown
um that we are an efficient organization
doing more with less
foreign
thank you for taking my question uh does
this mean you have to rely more on
contracted labor or contracted trucks or
doesn't make any difference
it it does thank you for the question
representative Petrie it does make a
difference
um particularly this year as we try to
compensate for the um
for the vacancy rates
historically we have always relied on
Hyatt plows even even in the pre-2011
when we had more more staff we like to
say we we are staffed for summer
maintenance and we augment our staff
with hired plows for the winter
maintenance
routinely
follow-up question also your
State Prison do you use any labor from
the state prison for a cleanup and
whatever
we do have a program where we work with
um
um uh
trying to think of a nicer way to say
than president prison labor but we do
have a program uh with the state prison
where we have work Crews that help
particularly with um
interstate and roadside litter cleanup
I'm going to refer to my uh assistant uh
oh Dave do you happen to know
um yeah we we take about 12 folks on uh
on a daily basis throughout the year
um at times we've taken more so we have
actually four different places that take
work Crews at District three office at
District Five office takes out Crews to
work on the highway fix guide rail do
trash removal cutting trees and and so
forth abridge maintenance folks take a
small crew in the summer to help them
wash bridges in our view of traffic take
some folks to help with the non-federal
funded portion of our pavement marking
program but that's become much tougher
with us for us since covet so we're
still doing that program but it's not as
efficient as it was four or five years
ago and we'll keep working to make it as
efficient as possible so we can make
that the best use of of those folks we
appreciate their help very much in the
cooperation we have from Department of
Corrections in that program
good thank you so that's a very top
level start of our budget presentation
I'd like to turn it over to Andre Brier
who talk about the general fund
Mr chairman members of the committee uh
again for the record Andre Brier Deputy
Commissioner the last time we briefed
you I walked you through a little more
detail about these programs here I'll
just uh say that uh
you know the minuscule portion of the
budget that is General funded that the
commissioner referred to is this right
this is our Personnel operating costs
for the Bureau of Aeronautics Rail and
Transit
um in all three of these modes you see
quite a large pass-through Federal
funding
um
Dynamic that's all handled by our
general funded offices and and Personnel
in those offices
the next slide you'll see that uh what I
just said which is uh primarily Transit
is funded by federal funds again federal
funds pass through all three of these
modes
um
but it is a small proportion there you
can see in the FY 2024 general fund
budget just 1.6 million will be
allocated to uh the division of Aviation
or Aeronautics Rail and Transit and fy25
just slight uh bump from that that's
primarily uh in the benefits lines
for our unfunded additional needs I'll
only uh point out a couple things here
with your Indulgence I would like to
talk about the Aeronautics program
specialist three position that we
requested
um and the
the implications of funding that just in
general when we do uas drone operations
we do it
at 18 percent of the cost that it would
cost us to contract it out so highly
efficient when we do it with uh existing
employees
the second thing is when we do uas
survey
for for instance a highway project we do
it about five times faster than
conventional survey methods so I think I
I tongue-in-cheek told this committee
the last time we were together that that
at D.O.T we take pictures of things and
infrastructure not people that is true
but this capability is really
revolutionary and when you when you uh
when you see what's happening Nationwide
with Highway projects
with airport repaving resurfacing the
verification we can do the ensuring of
quality of work this more than pays for
itself over time
so those are those are a couple uh key
points there another point I would make
is uh
you know various states that we deal
with and we're engaged through our TR
through our uh trade organizations ashdo
um primarily this other states are are
fairly far ahead on this and are already
realizing quite significant savings
um realized a 72 percent cost savings
over traditional methods and and they've
they've had their program for
significantly longer than us you see uh
States like Minnesota that are
implementing things called virtual twins
that can you can essentially really cut
down and do remotely a lot of the
inspection work that happens on
structures such as Bridges and other
infrastructure so quite exciting
the last point I'll make with this
position is just a comparison in our
region right now Vermont similar size
similar infrastructure they have six UAV
Pilots with additional four to five that
they have trained
Maine has five UAV Pilots additional
five to six trained Connecticut has 17
UAV Pilots
Massachusetts has eight they also quite
they extensively use contractors which
is why that number's a little smaller
New Hampshire has one
and we have more than one uas so we have
more than one platform right now we have
two highly capable platforms newly
acquired one has lidar capabilities that
will significantly improve our ability
to support Highway projects we have one
operator so one operator can only
operate one drone this position will let
us significantly expand our support to
Highway projects right now the uh the
delay that we have on Highway projects
goes all so his backlog R1 pilot
is all the way back at July 2022. he's
the requests that were put in last
summer he's just getting to now because
of the backlog
all right thank you Miss June uh thank
you for taking my question on this uh
and I was going to ask you about the
lidar can you do survey work
would that would that lidar which how
much does that save and uh oh it's a
tremendous so that that goes into the
overall cost savings when I say we do it
about you know uh at about 18 percent of
the cost of contractors that that's
going to save a lot
um we were uh we were able to give a
presentation to governor and Council uh
last summer beginning of last summer
where we kind of rolled through how we
deploy this technology on uh in this
case it was an airport project
and it pretty much wowed everybody
um I think uh several counselors noted
publicly at the time that uh they were
quite impressed with the capability and
it's quality control too so we can check
on our contractors and verify their work
as being done properly through things
like thermal imagery
so we can verify that as they lay down
tarmac the seams are correct right a
little hard to check from the naked eye
but a lot of capability implicit in this
in this system
thank you with regards to the other
states and also what you're envisioning
in New Hampshire are these full-time
positions yeah so the other states when
I mentioned uh this so six for Vermont
eight for Massachusetts five for Maine
17 for Connecticut those are the full
time they have other
um positions trained and and just to be
completely up front my vision as this is
under my portfolio is not to keep
growing our Bureau of Aeronautics we're
not going to be adding positions
willy-nilly or uh even significantly in
the future I think the future of our uas
program is to train and cross-train our
existing employees to be able to operate
these especially some of our uh
individuals that have volunteered to do
this in our Bureau of bridge maintenance
and
um in our operations uh uh division so
you know we're we're the state of New
Hampshire we're Frugal my vision for
this program Frugal but effective so I
think with these two drone operators one
of them can always act in a training
capacity as we build that capability out
with our existing Workforce very
difficult to do with one because he's
trying to juggle projects and
and like I said his backlog is is over
six months right now
thank you Mr
do you have asked
estrogen do you have an estimate of cost
for these two items actually the
unfunded additional needs that you'd
like
yes ma'am
it's about a hundred thousand dollars a
hundred thousand about a hundred
thousand dollars for the position right
thank you yeah well and and the uh
Transit as well the transit need
um do you want me to talk today I
normally I want to speak to that too
yeah so I do I uh with with that
physician as the commissioner said about
about a hundred
um
the the other unfunded requirement is
the state operating match for rural and
urban transit to access additional
available iija funds now we put put that
in as a as a request
um as an additional need with the
anticipation of Greater federal funds so
we could access those
um
because that didn't make it into the
governor's budget
um there's we put this on here so we
could more or less
um just point out that there are
municipalities and the advocacy
community that are going to be
testifying during during budget hearings
as to what they would do with this need
we have a a whole laundry list that the
uh that the transit providers provided
us as to what they could do with various
funding levels what happens if they
don't get these matching funds and
really when it boils down
is if they don't have these matching
phones just limits the availability of
so um oh I'm sorry based on what you
just said
um
so by not investing
there are a large number of federal
dollars that we're losing is that what
you mean that we have the potential that
we would that we would leave those on
the table all right thank you typically
you know typically these are um
um you know rural and urban Transit
facilities State of New Hampshire we
have historically provided very little
funding to assist with their with their
matching costs so the majority of the of
of of the required matching funding
which is generally about 50 percent for
the operating cost falls on the
municipalities and they have advocated
for a greater role of the state in
helping to fund uh public transit so
um with the Advent of the additional
iija funds
in our additional needs we had
recognized you know
proportionally the you know the amount
of additional federal funds you know an
argument could be made to come with with
an additional level of uh State matching
funds um at the end of the at the end of
the budget it wasn't included it was one
of the additional needs that we had had
pointed out uh because of the increase
in federal funds
um
but I'm but I'm sure through the budget
process the transit providers you may be
hearing with them so that's why we
wanted to just make sure you understood
so you don't have a recommended amount
you'd like to put here we will wait and
see what the um those who are coming to
testify will say we had a we had a
recommended amount in our in our agency
budget request could you just tell me
what it is it was around 100 it was
around fifty five hundred thousand
dollars in FY 24 and around 1.6 million
dollars in FY 25. and that was
proportional that wasn't the total match
I know you you probably hear from the
transit advisors that they that there's
a there's even a greater need than than
we had identified but our additional
needs had identified you know a um
a level commence commensurate with the
additional Federal funding and and that
was proportional but like the
commissioner said when the transit
providers come they're going to most
likely make a case for significantly
more than yeah I I met with one of the
transit providers and they they're
getting kind of squeezed from the fits
yeah because they're required to do
certain things that they're not fully
compensated for so the the better they
do the federal things the worse off they
are all right so it's kind of you know
kind of inverse for the state's benefit
Mary I remember Victoria Sheen when she
was here she spoke at length about the
need for us to demonstrate more support
um so that we could drive more federal
dollars so I think that's something we
thank you Mr chair a lot of us are upset
over the fact that many people going
down the roads don't pay their share and
gas tax and I wonder if you could help
us with telling us maybe through the DMV
how many electric cars there are a
multi-fueled thing so we can kind of get
that out there the next time we try to
pass something to get those people to
pay some share of of the road toll sure
um I don't have that information on the
tip of my tongue I know you wouldn't but
I think if you can get it to us sure
yeah next year we we put in a bill and
so I said oh what do we need that for
you know we can see
twenty percent of the cars are not
paying anything
and the electric cars that put an extra
thousand pounds of battery on the road
and wearing it out even more versus the
80 pounds of gasoline I drive down the
road so yeah current registration
um of electric vehicles as the
commissioner said we get you an exact
number that's always growing
um you hear 8 000 kicked around but
that's growing constantly yeah and and
the other the ones that have kind of
multi-fuel that they might run on
propane or something like other or you
know those those are people that aren't
paying at gasoline tax yeah and I know
there are several bills through the
legislation this time you probably have
seen are following them that um
uh
attempt to address part of part of part
of the issue you've testified at a
couple of them so yeah yeah it's it's
one thing to say yeah they're riding
free but when they put an extra thousand
pounds on the road
in battery you know that's that's even
more aware that just a regular car so I
think if we know those data we can start
making a fuss yeah thank you sir that's
the long-term
negative forecast for for the highway
fund is also LinkedIn
yeah can you just tell me what iija
stands for I'm sorry it was the uh
infrastructure something I J Investment
in jobs active investment in jobs act
thank you yeah you caught me up guys
you'll hear it called iija
infrastructure investment and jobs Act
the bipartisan infrastructure law bill
is the way some people refer to it as
well
and I apologize I had it on the tip of
my tongue last year at this time when it
was when it was new and stuff but I just
want to back up one just for a second uh
in full Finance
last term we talked about uas
deployment around the state not just
Transportation but we had also safety
and we had
I don't know who all were we had
multiple divisions or multiple agencies
that were doing this and at that time it
was just rhetorical discussion is there
like a central uas
Nexus somewhere that we you know you can
get some cross training and different
disciplines from different departments
or whatever I don't even understand the
whole thing but yeah that's a that's a
great question
um through uh
through governor and Council
um
we did we have a current contract for
about 167 thousand dollars that's being
used to fund a
a more wide-ranging look at how we
Implement our uas program how we best
and most efficiently deploy those assets
into the future so that's an ongoing
effort right now that was funded last
year
um
or is we the state so so we as in dot
okay now our relationship with the
Department of Safety and other
departments that use uas's we have a
very close working relationship with
those departments fundamentally
it is a different Mission set so I'm a
former Air Force pilot it's it's
analogous to
you know to uh
uh transport flying versus you know
fighter combat operations versus close
air support these are fundamentally
different missions the law enforcement
uas mission is something that is quite
unique and has its own training
requirements on its own limitations
that's not certainly not the type of U.S
flying
that we would be involved with ours is
really focused on infrastructure
we're not chasing anything we're
loitering and we're taking pictures you
know so but but we are closely aligned
and constantly
um coordinating with the other
departments and I think also to some
degree Bureau of Aeronautics has kind of
they did jurisdictional oversight over
some of the administration of that too
yeah by Statute
um we are the lead agency uh the Bureau
of Aeronautics on uas capabilities
having said that we give great deference
to uh to our law enforcement Partners
foreign that's so that's uh that's the
summary of our general fund portion so
the two takeaways are of that are
um that you will be hearing we've talked
about the transit need
um as well as the um additional position
um just to uh support the uas program
and again we identified that as a
um as a as a what feels an efficiency
and and Innovation but we certainly
understand the
um
the hesitancy in in terms of growing
state government and stuff but it does
it does I think Andre had done a good
job identifying that
um it is it is it is and could be an
efficiency in terms of paying for itself
over the long term
so with that I'd like to turn to oh I'm
sorry I I had uh one question uh whether
the with the rate of inflation that we
have how much is that affecting your
Bridge Building
portion I mean is it in it and we know
it's not linear because some things are
costing a heck of a lot more
you know and how much effect does that
have on what you're doing
um
it's it is having it is having an effect
uh we've been
um but hopefully it's somewhat um
stabilizing but we've seen costs
compared to what we had budgeted or
planned on we've seen costs escalation
of of 15 to 20 percent so in a holistic
type of look that would be 15 or 20
percent
um less work that we would be doing
um I spoke about uh the uh
infrastructure Act and the additional
Federal funding that we got so New
Hampshire got about
um
about 25 additional Federal funding than
we had previously uh to that bill
um it came with a lot of expectations of
of
um of uh more work being done
um we are finding that with the rate of
inflation that um it's it's allowing us
to
um essentially sustain the the program
and absorb those uh inflationary impacts
um
but not necessarily putting out a whole
lot more projects so in a nutshell
that's kind of been the impact of the
inflation that we've seen over the last
year
thank you
so with that we'll turn to
um slide 12 and Dave rodrigue the
assistant commissioner is going to talk
about the turnpike fund portion of our
budget
thank you commissioner Mr chairman and
members of the committee for the record
my name is David rodrigue assistant
commissioner for DOT
um back on the turnpike system the
turnpike system is a concise part of our
transportation system it's well defined
it includes three segments I-95 from the
Massachusetts border to the main border
the Spalding turnpike from its Terminus
at I-95 North to the Milton Wakefield
Town Line or so in the Effie Everett
from Nashua continuing up through
Manchester and joining I-93 and ending
here in Concord so those three segments
include about 89 miles of of highway 172
Bridges seven toll plazas we Define the
turnpike system as an Enterprise fund
meaning all funds elected through the
tolls must stay on the turnpike system
those funds go for our operating and
maintenance costs a Debt Service our our
in our work and a Capital Improvements
in fiscal year 22 we processed about 112
million transactions
um for
143.8 million dollars of total revenue
on the next slide you'll see the
um history of the turnpike Revenue
you'll see that in 2019 we thought
things were looking great and revenues
were increasing and we all know what
happened then at the end of
um fiscal year 20 I guess
um when everything changed we saw some a
significant decline in Revenue we've
seen a little bit of a bounce back from
that and we have Consultants who look at
our transportation system and look at
economic factors around the country and
people's commuting habits and what
they're telling us now is they think
we've seen most of the recovery
um from covid in that bottom line
people's traveling habits and commuting
habits especially have changed uh a
little bit so as we look to the Future
we're seeing just stay or projecting
just a modest increase in traffic
volumes that relate directly to
um revenue for for the turnpike system
um so again we're looking at at
um funding being flat for the future
when it comes to the turnpike budget we
did not have a additional prior
prioritized needs but because we have
Bonds on the turnpike system they're
very specific in what we do first and
it's no surprise the very first thing we
do is collect the money you got to do
that first then then you got to operate
and maintain the system and then we have
to do our maintenance in what comes last
is our Capital project so we have a
number of capital projects that we're
working on that that are funded with
Turnpike funds
um most notably we have the general
Sullivan bridge will be replacing we
have the Epi Everett widening that goes
from Nashua to to Manchester we have
exit six and seven in Manchester that we
would like to reconstruct and we have
Beau conquered I-93 a large portion of
that here is funded with Turnpike
dollars so as we look at our Capital
program we're seeing those projects
being pushed out later and later
um in a in a capital plan so this year
we'll be starting our update of the
10-year plan process and when we do that
folks we're going to get to talk about
what our priorities are and when we can
realistically expect to to build those
projects but it's important for you for
you all to understand that while we're
getting by we we have things that we had
planned to do sooner than we're going to
to be able to do them with our current
and with that commissioner
um are there any questions on the
turnpike fund before we move to like the
highway funded portion yeah I just would
yeah thanks um the programs that you
listed
um are they all part of the turnpike I
don't know where Manchester exits six
and seven is if that's part of the
turnpike if you're not so these are all
the all the four things you listed are
all Turnpike thank you for Turnpike
projects yep and I would point out
representative Petrie in respect to your
your prior question so on the federally
funded side where
um you know the additional federal funds
and the inflation have kind of offset
each other on the turnpike side uh
Revenue has been flat so as you know
costs increase
um
uh we're as as Dave said we're pushing
thing we're pushing things out to take
longer uh longer to get to at the same
um funding levels so
you said something about the general
Sullivan Bridge what what's with that
that's uh it's that scene it looked like
it was complete except for the approach
uh if you if you if you drive over it
there's a there's an old the old rusted
section of the bridge is being removed
and replaced with a
once that estimated cost
so moving on to the highway fund
overview for the Department
um
when we talk uh on on slide 16 is uh
just some of the things that we had
covered previously with the highway
funding kind of a reminder the highway
fund is not the dot and the dot is not
the highway fund Revenue to the highway
fund is generated from the gas tax
primarily and registration fees was a
connect those are collected by
Department of Safety they do the revenue
projections revenue from the highway
fund is appropriated to various agencies
dot safety judicial branch and Justice
all received part of it the splits in FY
22 are listed the iso in 2022
New Hampshire dot received about 60
percent of the highway fund uh Revenue
that was appropriated from it uh 40 went
to Department of Safety and other
agencies as well as about uh 13 to 14
percent of the highway fund Revenue that
went to municipalities
um
and one of the points
um the that I had made when when I
talked about the breakup of our budget
between the operating budget and the
municipal and construction half of the
budget
um the highway fund is the primary
source of funding for our operating
budget so which is you know very
pertinent to what we're talking about
here today the operating budget as
opposed to some of the capital projects
in the 10-year plan that David talked
about
so on slide 17 is a um a lot of numbers
so I apologize for this I know the
committee in the past has asked for this
uh slide has asked for this information
um and I I just like to just step you
through it because it is somewhat
pertinent in how the highway fund works
and how the gas tax is distributed to
some of the elements in our budget as
well as some of the other agencies
so the highway so the gas tax the road
toll if you will is uh
22.2 cents
um
per gallon
and an FY 22 that represented a a
certain level of Revenue so by Statute
12 percent of the gas tax goes to cities
and towns through block grant Aid which
is administered through Department of
Transportation so in our budget we have
a um we have a
an au we have an organizational unit for
that block grant Aid and that funding
that goes to cities and towns
statutorily 2.6 cents or about 3 percent
of the gas tax is
um
about three cents minus the two 12 minus
the
um 12 percent to cities and talents so
about 2.6 cents of the gas tax goes to a
restricted account uh called the
betterment account which is uh also an
org in our budget
um which goes towards
um
uh kind of state roads heavy heavy road
maintenance the betterment program is
the primary source of our routine
maintenance Paving Ever every year so it
goes to City so it goes to
um it's restricted to go towards
um State highways and bridges
um
and then out of the 22.6 and and 2014
there was a um a bill passed SB 367 that
restricted uh
3.7 cents of that to a restricted
account that it goes to pay the um
ultimately goes to pay the debt service
on the um
on the tipia loan that we took out to
fund the I-93 construction project so
while the I-93 construction project is
done
part of the gas tax that went into a
place to support that work we are still
paying for that and we will be paying
for that for some for some for some time
and I have a little bit more information
on the next slide of that
so that's kind of the waterfall on on
that side motor vehicle fees are also a
substantial portion of the highway fund
um again 12 percent of the motor vehicle
fees go to that block grant Aid cities
and towns and you can see there the net
motor vehicle fees
um and motor vehicle fines also go
toward the highway fund so
I just wanted to kind of walk walk you
through how the road toll and motor
vehicle fees and fines work the very
last four columns do summarize the uh
split of funding for
um how much percentage-wise goes to the
municipalities how much goes to other
agencies and how much goes to the
Department of Transportation and there
are some rsas that that govern a certain
minimal portion of the highway fund that
goes to
other agencies and the Department of
Transportation
so hopefully that's not
too much information but that's I I
wanted to just point that out because I
said that it's been asked for in the
past but it does correlate to several
areas of funding within our within our
budget that again are driven by
um by the revenue stream that's
collected by the motor vehicle fees and
and and the um and the road toll
I had mentioned in passing the SB 367 uh
uh tiffia Debt Service so
um there was established in statute of
waterfall that that came with that so
essentially
4.2 cents of the gas tax is dedicate of
that road toll was dedicated toward uh
this tipia Debt Service
um again 12 of of that goes first to
Municipal block grant Aid
um
then it goes to the debt service for the
tipia financing
we did a um when we when we financed
I-93 we were able to defer interest
payments for
um
uh 10 for five years after the project
was completed so the project was
completed in 2020 so we were able to
defer both during the construction and
for five years after the completion of
construction the full principal Debt
Service on that loan and I wanted to put
breaking this up
um in in this slide because
but the duration of while 93 was being
constructed and until the full principal
Debt Service kicks in there was a
waterfall where the additional funding
from that 4.2 cents went to
um
state aid Bridge funding and it also
went to uh Paving rural roads and
addressing rural bridges in 2025 The
Debt Service full Debt Service and
payment of the principal does does kick
in and then and after that
um
uh funding for state aid Municipal
Municipal Bridges will begin to decline
as revenue is projected to decline in
the in the highway fund as a result of
the gas tax
um and also the 20 million dollars or so
um 20 21 million dollars or so that we
have been able to put towards
um rural roads and bridges will now go
to Debt Service so that will leave a
hole
um in the in the program that has done a
um so it's less of a uh uh an issue I
think with this biennial budget but at
the end of this biennium and certainly
when we get to the next budgets it's
something to
um as one to bring to your attention
because there will be something
um that we'll have to reckon with
representative right thank you for
taking my question uh I see a few
suspended a gas tax by many people think
that the gas prices are too high and
that would cause a what 174 million
dollar hole
depending on you know that's for the
whole year but uh yeah that would be
quite a quite a burden on on your uh
spend it for a whole year I sure would
yes or or even part of it I mean you
know one I mean it's one twelfth right
probably for a month or several months
yep so I mean but that's
what would what would happen
as far as the budget is concerned I mean
it would would you have to just stop
some of your bridge building or what I
mean
you sure I mean you got to plow the
roads I mean you gotta you've got to
maintain a rule well that's yeah that
would be an interesting question most of
our bridge building and stuff is done
with federal funds so it wouldn't
necessarily have as much of an impact on
our construction program certainly the
uh Personnel that oversee the
construction program but it could have
uh uh uh a very real effect on our
ability to plow roads and things like
that as the um
as like like I said the bulk of our
operating budget is funded by the
highway fund and not the federal funds
the federal funds can you do other other
than Federal highways
no no so that's that's another so you
restricted in that in that sense right
and and getting back to the
the getting back to the SB 367 and the
4.2 Cent gas tax I mean this was that
money was pledged particularly for Rural
roads and bridges which are about
one-third of the mileage of State
highways that we maintain are not
eligible for federal funds
um so we rely on you know State funds
whether it be the betterment program
that I touched on or these funds to
thank you thank you commissioner for
coming today
um
so when when the Tiffy of waterfall
stops
that's that's going to cut back on the
paving program but is that does this
does the force sense also sunset at the
same time
the port said sunsets when The Debt
Service is paid off in 2035.
so it will continue on that won't okay I
thought it was going to be with two
holes no no
so I'll I'll keep going if there are
more questions the next two slides
um
and and just a few things about the
highway fund that I'd want to point out
and I'll be uh
um
try to be respectful of everybody's time
slide 19 is a is kind of a graph of of
the total unrestricted Revenue in the
highway fund over over time so you can
see back in the you know the
previous five years of the prior decade
a declining
um
rate of
Revenue into the highway fund and since
2016 it has grown a little bit but the
outcome from this this chart is to
emphasize that the that the revenue into
the highway fund is is is very flat it's
projected to stay flat
um and potentially in the future with
EVs and other other increased gas
mileage decline incrementally so as we
talk about you know
um you know continued inflationary costs
and things like that
um budgetarily you know this level of
funding is is something to look at and
address
on the next slide slide 20 it represents
um in in the in the top bar with some of
the details
this is just meant to show that there
have been a number of
um
you know one time fixes one time sources
one time uh infusions of funding into
the uh Highway fund that have allowed us
to help balance the budget over the
years so there have been things like a
thirty dollar registrations uh
surcharge in 2010 and 11.
um
some things where we sold a a bridge the
I-95 Bridge we sold it to the turnpike
system so the turnpike system paid the
highway fund uh over a number of years
uh for that asset which was a way of
helping bail out the highway fund
um
most recently there have been several
uh transfers general fund transfers into
the highway fund most notably at the end
of FY uh 22 I know in the Senate was
looking ahead and looking at the status
of the highway fund they put 50 million
dollars of
um
a general fund Surplus into the highway
fund to sustain it for the next biennium
so
um that's not terribly different than
what Washington is doing with the
Federal Highway fund as well with with
routine infusions of General funds to
keep the highway fund afloat
but that's the scope in order of
magnitude of of what has been done over
the years to sustain the highway fund
and if you look at page 21 the next
slide that is
um that is the status of the highway
fund that is the Surplus fund statement
through the upcoming biennium and a
couple of points that I want to make uh
um on on this
um
you know it does show at the very end of
the biennium and fy25 a um a positive
balance in the highway fund so that is
being used I I pointed out the the
infusion of 50 million dollars in FY 22
into the highway fund that's helping
sustain us through this biennium
um there are a few notes again with that
level Revenue that I talked about that
uh give us a little bit of a pause as as
we look at the you know long-term
budgetary stability here
um
one of the things
that we had pointed out in our Edition
and our additional needs uh was was some
of the inflationary impacts of the major
elements that that we use for
particularly winter maintenance
um uh salt and fuel of the two biggest
drivers and
um those have
um those have gone up and and we were
projecting them to to go up again to
meet our budget targets we had level
budget targets to meet we had identified
those inflationary cost drivers and the
additional needs and those additional
needs were not included in in the in the
budget the rationale of that was
um you know some of the inflationary
needs are are fairly speculative it's
hard to pinpoint how much gas is going
to cost next year or in two years same
thing with with road salt and diesel
fuel and things like that so the
decision
um as part of this budget was was was
made to keep it level funded and if
those inflationary costs manifest
themselves in the future we could go
back to fiscal for um for a transfer to
address that
um
historically we have not
fully budgeted winter maintenance as
well we've always we we the department
typically try to budget for a three-year
average of winter maintenance costs
um
uh historically we have underfunded
winter maintenance and uh every year for
the last uh for the last five or six
years that I've been around and remember
we have gone back to
um
um we have gone back to fiscal committee
during the winter to
um you know seek additional funds of
transfer from the highway fund Surplus
to carry us through the winter we just
went last
was it last Friday or the Friday before
last Friday it's a fiscal for a 3.4
million dollar Surplus transfer to carry
us through through this winter so
um with those inflationary costs uh with
those
um
trend of historically under under
budgeting winter maintenance if those if
those costs manifest themselves over the
next two years and we are going back to
seek transfers this
13.1 million dollar balance at the end
of the
um at the end of the biennium may not be
enough to carry us through
um
again revenues uh assumed to be flat
those may or may not come in a little
bit more but um
I just wanted to point that out on the
circle statement that those are some of
the concerns that that we sit see and
wanted to articulate
um the other concern we see in in this
is uh is in the lapse assumption uh
lapse is a typically budgeted on a look
back and and and trying to average it
out over the last uh few years I'm not
sure if it's three or five but
um over the over the pandemic period of
uh 20 21 20 2020 2021
um
we had significant lapses both because
of hiring freezes and both
um because of other
um
decisions not to expend money because of
the concern of the status of the highway
fund and things like that so I think the
lapses that we had shown in those years
were inordinately high and I think
that's reflected in in what's assumed
for 24 and 25
um but but again those those High lapses
are concerning to us we do have a high
vacancy rate that we're trying to knock
down
um you heard the governor's budget
presentation it does include a 10
percent increase for state employees
hopefully that'll stem the tide and and
when we can rebuild some of that
um but with the with this estimated
lapse it could be a challenge for us to
meet it and we would not uh it would be
difficult for us to be in a position of
having to not hire people and not um
um and artificially limit the work in
order to meet the lapse
um
thank you Mr chairman I I'm looking at
this are you are the lapses you're
considering for 24 and 25
27 million and 28 million yes sir yes
so quick numbers yeah they're quite High
compared to you know what we have in uh
you know budgeted and adjusted
authorized of fy23 for example so
um
so it is it it is a an issue that we
want to talk about the the other last
point on the
um
Surplus statement here that I like to
make and and it's and it's and it's kind
of endemic of the structural deficit
within the highway fund if you look at
the annual year
um the current year activity which is
the line right below the total
deductions
you'll see particularly in 24 and 25 and
and even this year we are
I don't know if it's called deficit
spending but certainly the
Appropriations exceed
um
the revenue by you know 30 million
37 million 44 million dollars so that
structural deficit is eating away at the
highway fund
um it's a big reason and that look ahead
why the Senate did Park put 50 million
dollars of general fund Surplus to carry
us through the biennium
um
but um
I think it does serve to illustrate the
precariousness of the highway fund so
I'll leave it at that but those are some
we can take questions later you look
like you were going to ask a question
representative Buco but I didn't want to
my
my question was actually about about um
mechanical services and equipment and I
didn't know if you didn't get to that
I'm going to get to that next yep so
that was a high level overview of the
highway fund on slide 22
um some of the additional needs in our
budget that were funded
um you know we're we're the increase in
debt service payments uh the block grant
increases to um which are tied to the
revenue
um increases at least compared Revenue
increases compared to the last biennium
um transfers to other agencies including
dot General Services
Department of administrative services
in Department of Justice for their costs
increase
other other agencies were giving
budgetary targets of a three percent
increase we were given a level zero
percent increase in our budget targets
um
but there are transfers to other
agencies for support and stuff that we
did we had identified those needs in the
um in the additional needs column and
they were funded in in the governor's
are we sticking with our 26 percent
what's the 26 yeah for other agencies
yes yeah yes yeah about that
that's a that's a law isn't it yeah
so the other thing representative Buco
um you had asked about the fleet um one
of the asks that we did have in the
level funded
um we we had um we had a request of
about 10.4 million dollars over the
biennium to sustain our Fleet
Investments about
um
about two-thirds of that was funded in
the budget for six million dollars
um and and additional to that is also um
the two hundred thousand dollars which
go along with the vehicle purchases for
vehicle um outfitting
so those were the additional needs in
the budget that were
um included
on page 23 I overview the um additional
needs that we had identified in our
agency budget request that were not
funded we had identified
about six Highway funded positions that
that weren't funded
um you know we'll we'll find ways to
cover those needs
the driveway permitting positions were
an attempt to improve customer service
improve and centralize the driveway
permitting process it does have a lot of
interaction with um with with uh with
folks but um
like I said it was an improvement that
that we have felt had Merit but um uh I
it wasn't funded in the governor's
budget will continue to address those
needs with our existing uh resources
um the next four bullets
um identify you know what we had
identified for cost increases
um in uh you know inflationary impacts
both in salt and Fuel and what we're
paying for hired hired plows annually
and increases in utility cost so those
costs
um
we we believed we were making a a good
faith um
uh
honest effort to reasonably
um project and identify those costs that
we think we uh could very well see in
the next by biennium certainly we know
um
um from looking backwards at the last
biennium salt
um
so road salt for example has increased
about 54 percent we've seen that in our
in our bids but we are not reflecting
those additional costs as as as we go
forward in this budget
um
for all the reasons that we had talked
about
um before
um
its effect on the bottom line of the
highway fund the
um potential uncertainty of it
um but
um
we understand the volatility of the of
of of of the projections but um we are
concerned that when we if and when we do
incorporate
come across those inflationary impacts
that uh
um
uh we may not be able to address them
so those were the bulk of the additional
unfunded needs that we had identified
and again they were primarily you know
tied to inflationary aspects of of fuel
and materials
we did have and the last two bullets
there
um
I had mentioned on the fleet Investments
we did have a request of about 10.4
million dollars that was the level that
we've identified that we feel we we need
to invest in the fleet to um
to keep it up and sustain and sustain
the fleet without without losing ground
ultimately in the governor's budget it
was a little less than that which is
which is which is great we'll we'll make
do with what we have but in the past
when we have under
invested in the fleet
um we have gotten really behind the
eight ball by not keeping up with
routine levels of of investment and
keeping up with our equipment so
um
uh I guess at the end of this I'm
concluding our presentation with the
thought that it would be
um you know we think it would be
um very advantageous to continue the
um investment in in the fleet to keep
that and and ask for consideration of
fully funding our Fleet investment
request
well on a point uh so you're figuring is
about 120 million dollars that's what
you that's what your fleet's worth and
to replace it every what probably 10
years correct is that is that where that
10.4 million comes comes from
um I'll have Dave can speak to that a
little bit more the next two slides well
the final two slides
um
you have some very specific
complete information but
yes I think our y'all let you speak to
it Dave and I'll follow up against
probably this have you yeah and it's in
the book okay
have you uh find it hard to uh get
supplies to build your trucks
I mean it the supply chain specifically
so yeah see the answer to that question
is it's very difficult today number one
to purchase a new vehicle and get it
delivered number two when our existing
Vehicles break down it's very difficult
to get parts and sometimes we're delayed
in the repair waiting for parts and then
as as you point out
um we do build our own trucks so we buy
the the frame and Chassis we buy the
dump bodies separate we buy the
Hydraulics separate and build those and
like all things that are delivered that
takes a a little bit more time to today
is as well which from my perspective is
is all the more reason why we we keep up
with it
um we did give you these these budget
books in on page 29 of the book
is our Fleet statistics as of July 1st
2022 and I want to show you this table
because this table includes our expected
age and our expected usage so as you can
see
um those are the first two two columns
after the descriptions as as you can see
each of our pieces
um depending on the type may have a an
estimated expected life of 15 years 12
years
um some uh 10 years in summer six and
and eight so when we come up with the
actual budget cost it's a a real
calculation based on our entire fleet
composition as is summarized on on this
sheet
if that makes sense
and we do have a a slide that speaks to
that that's that's a little bit larger
but it we don't have an included the
expected age in that but
yes certainly so um
I've hit on a number of these things so
the very last slide slide 24 to sum sum
things up
um I talked about the highway fund
Revenue situation and the structural and
solvency
um and we are still uh challenged with
employee retention looking at a current
current vacancy rate of over 25 percent
um
on the operations and maintenance side
you know
a big part of that high vacancy rate I
think is
um you know attributed to our
non-competitive salaries and hopefully
the 10 percent uh raise in the budget is
going to help
um address that
um we have had some declining service
levels in a number of areas in past
budget years we have identified program
needs for
um tree removal and Mowing and graffiti
removal and some of those needs that
that we have that we have
identified but have not been able to get
to
um
in past and and past budgets those have
not been been funded
um
but they are still very real
um very real needs
um
we didn't we didn't put those types of
um requests and our additional needs and
and the budget here this time primarily
because of the vacancy rate
um and and you know we need to focus on
rebuilding and taking care of what we
have
um first and foremost before before
adding more but
um
I didn't want to leave the impression
that with level funding and and some of
those things that that everything is is
um finding good because there are still
uh some of these needs that
um the reasons I mentioned we haven't
identified but they are still
um
they are still very real real needs
and they are long-term challenges for us
to to address
um
so some of the things there
um we've talked about the fleet under
budgeting we've talked about the
the backlogs and driveway permitting we
tried to identify some some resources to
address that but um we'll we'll keep
trying to address it as best we can
um
I had mentioned the
looming loss of SB 367 Revenue toward
Paving and bridges ending after 2025
um and through some of the questions
we've addressed The Limited State
funding for non-federal Aid eligible
state roads
um
long-term State funding for rural and
urban Transportation Urban Transit
programs is going to continue to be a a
need as well
um and and in the very long term we
still do not bring much State dollars to
match the federal program compared to
other states we rely on
um
Turnpike toll credits to utilize our
federal funds at a hundred percent
versus the typical uh 20 match that is
that is required
um and uh and then the long term with
the declining waterfall and the SB 367 I
mentioned the declining funding toward
the state aid bridge program as well too
so those are some of the longer term
challenges
um
that I just want to place on on on on
your awareness as we go through through
the budget
um mainly for ratification and and
um
in your information so
well I think a comment you made early on
certainly applies and that is you can't
you can't live for the laps
right you know I think I think your
lapse is going to start shrinking
by necessity right
because you can't deliver what you need
to deliver with what you got
right I agree
that was the point we're trying to make
with with one of the concerns with the
um
Circle statement as it's reflected
currently yeah because tradition isn't
the lamps right
yeah we like some of the sb2 that says
the lapse we have to do we don't have to
fix the roads right right yeah
any other questions
huh
uh
I just want to recall that during the
last budget cycle we had to um
subsidize the the fleet with
I I think it was actually Capital
funding that we we used
we can't um you know you know we can't
you can't the department can't operate
if it doesn't have a fleet if it doesn't
have vehicles
right and I I would like to comment I I
probably didn't articulate that well
when I said it but that that that's
that's that representative Buco is one
of the primary reasons that that we are
advocating for fully funding our Fleet
request because
um the legislature over the past few
budgets has been very good through
through a mix of of operating budget and
capital budget
um allowing us to kind of claw back and
build back up the fleet investment so
um it's it we we would we would hate to
see that
um
that investment diminished by not
keeping up with it right right right and
and you know it's it's just like
Building Maintenance you know you can't
if you don't we don't maintain it then
we're going to end up having to buy buy
whole new trucks instead of keeping up
what we have
thank you Mr chair and apologies for
being late I had a bill that took way
longer than I meant to I apologize just
a quick question of course a lot of your
concerns are because of the funding for
the highway finders affected by the
changing the mix of vehicles and all
that there are bills that obviously are
attempting to fix that even by forming a
committee or by fixing it so what are
your thoughts on how should the
legislator go about you know
properly taxing the people who use our
um
if you don't mind I'd kind of answer not
necessarily as the commissioner of dot
but a little bit more of a personal type
of opinion because I I don't know if we
as an agency have
um
you know formulated a policy well what
we have I mean I would say as a as an
agency we're relatively agnostic we can
identify the needs
um and and and how best to address those
needs funding wise becomes you know more
of the policy makers prerogative I do
think you know personally in a following
it that that things such as the
um that the road user fee
um things like that which get at
um equitability of funding um do make do
make sense to me
um there is an argument to make that you
know a road user fee whether based on
registration of some sort does fall a
little more
um heavily on you know the in-state
um
you know in in state people and doesn't
necessarily
take into account you know the tourism
traffic that are used in our our
highways as well too so
um
uh around the country particularly in
the West Oregon Washington and those
areas are looking very hard at much more
again that that equitability standpoint
of of of vehicle miles traveled type of
model
um
there are some pluses and minus with
that depending on your outlook
but again getting back to equity
somehow some some some
uh
payment of by how frequently or how much
you use the transportation system
um
would seem to make sense and I think is
in in keeping with the
um original intent of of the of the
highway fund which was set up to be a a
user fee you know through the through
the circuit of usage of gasoline so
yeah I have two questions thank you and
you can probably guess the second one
but
um what are your discussions around
raising some of the tolls how was the
last time tolls have been raised and my
second question is any anticipated plans
um
I think the last time the toll structure
was Ray was was changed was in uh 2009
um when when the tolls were raised to
um you know support the capital program
that that we uh that we have planned out
today
um
we have not broached any discussions
about uh toll increases others have
suggested it certainly as you compare to
other other other states New Hampshire
is one of the uh lowest in terms of toll
rates but um
as we just as we get into the 10-year
plan any changes to the 10-year plan
um there are changes every every every
two years so we'll have to see
um you know how that goes like I said
our our
our goal is is to present the needs and
what we can do with the existing funding
we have and to maybe suggest some ideas
of what could be done to either offset
or compensate that
um
I think it was about four years ago
through the 10-year plan process with
some of the questions
um
about redless bridges particularly on
the turnpike with some of the turnpike
Capital needs there was a um there was
we were asked by the executive Council
to look at what it would take to um
fund the capital program more
ambitiously and we did review and put
a toll increased package that that could
support that and through the through the
10-year plan process and through the
governor and executive Council it it was
not passed so
um
whether similar questions come up at
this 10 10-year plan or not
um I I can't say when Dave was talking
about particularly the turnpike program
we do have some very Stark decisions to
make on either our priorities what's
going to be done or or what's not going
um I think it is within our Realm to
raise the totals
um if we were to raise them by a dollar
so it would be two dollars
going both ways now that I have my easy
pass I never know what it is
um
what in the top of your head could you
do a quick estimate on how much money
um not not in my head I can go back and
ask the question I would point out
representative that uh by Statute the
toll rates are governed by the executive
Council the toll locations and and where
there are or aren't
um toll plazas are um seems like we have
done it before they had they lacked the
gumption to raise the tolls so we did it
in the past
through the legislation
maybe an hb2
I'm I I know all the discussions that we
have had it's been very very very
clearly stated that governor and Council
control the toll rates toll locations
and and boy the plazas are located
um that came up recently with Merrimack
tolls that it was uh the executive
Council who voted to
um zero out the uh the toll rates they
couldn't eliminate the tolls because
that the toll plaza locations are at the
discretion of the legislature but they
could set a zero
um a zero rate at those tolls and
ultimately then on the two areas in
Merrimack have been removed so thank you
you're welcome right uh thank you Mr
chairman
now
does the turnpike
revenues
cover all the cost of the turnpikes
because you can't you can't use that
money for other places correct correct
so yes it does it does so in other words
raising the tolls you're just going to
increase that that part of money so the
the when David pointed out the um the
waterfall
um
I'm gonna just find the right slide so
nope
12.
so the waterfall for the for the
turnpike revenues go towards and I think
it stated it wrong I think first and
foremost it goes to pay the debt service
The Debt Service comes off the top to
the bonds that have built the turnpike
system to date
um then it's operating in maintenance
cost then there is a certain level of r
r which is uh Rehabilitation and
restoration that we have to put in
satisfy the bondholders and keep the
turnpike in good working order so the
toll revenues that we have today do
cover
um all three of those needs The Debt
Service the operation and maintenance
and the r r work where we fall short
then and and what's the last thing that
gets funded are the of those of those
Capital needs those bigger projects to
either widen the Epi Everett Turnpike or
redo the interchanges that uh exit six
and seven things things like that so
um and those are driven by by cash flow
so after after
operations and maintenance after The
Debt Service after the r r work are
funded whatever is left you know can
then go to Capital
um as operation and maintenance costs go
up as RNR work goes up there's less and
less of available each year for Capital
funds so the cash flow for those capital
projects just extends out further and
further
so and the answer to your question
the turnpike revenue does does cover the
needs of of the turnpike it depends on
the capital needs whether you uh view
those as a
as a priority or a discretionary kind of
need
a follow-up the bond can it is that a
fixed amount uh term
uh in other words turn to 2035 in other
words we have to pay it till 2035
because of the bond is usually fixed
that way yes it is thank you
thank you Mr chair quick question covert
really did a job on your total funds
um could you use apple money to replace
any of that and based on your chart you
can't expect the long-term revenues to
come up again because they've leveled up
because more people are still working it
from home and that seems to become the
status quo so we really need to think
about something
how I mean how are you going to continue
to exist right
um I I do believe that Opera funds could
be used for replacing lost Revenue not
necessarily the
the cost Delta going going forward but
certainly for
um for lost Revenue incurred during that
time but
um
no And as far as going forward
the strategy to date with that with with
without the wherewithal to consider a
toll increase or or or or or other
infusion of funds you know has been to
um
be judicious with the capital projects
and and we've been honest through the
10-year plan projects uh through the
10-year plan process of of of
what can be done and what and what can't
be done and you know as we push those
projects out further or or maybe not do
them at all
um we'll have to have a weighing of of
if that's acceptable if that's an
acceptable level of service or not
um
well what New Hampshire depends on
tourism it's a huge revenue for us and
without a good system of Roads
Turnpike especially
um I think maybe we're being a little
silly not to think more aggressively
about raising the tolls then
I need to call somebody and find out how
so we've had a lot of talk over in
division one about the uh
exit 4A yes and they want us to tell you
to get going on it right now
what's the odds it's going to get worked
on soon
well exit 4A is continually to be worked
on one of the first contracts is
presently under construction if you
drive down 93 the next contract we're
trying very hard to get out the door
um
and there was some talk about you
haven't even bought all the property yet
that you need right
now that that's that's that's whether or
not we're going to do the Box Culvert or
right the spaghetti room right
um as far as buying the property we need
that tends to be a critical path in in
doing things so we bought the property
that we had needed to uh advertise and
construct the first the first contract
um we are presently by you know working
on acquiring the property that we need
to um to build and advertise for
construction The second contract which
would go um you know up to Route 28
Route 28 Bypass so that's in your budget
right now it is in our budget it's in
our Capital program yep thank you yep
and it's been it's being very actively
worked on
um yeah the delays and the and then and
the need to get it done
um as soon as possible
um has been part of the discussion with
the with the with the Box Culvert Our
concern has been that in in the town of
dairy is concerned that is we take a
step back with a
um different alternative at this at this
point
um it could delay
um getting that project advertised
you're welcome yeah thank you I want to
follow up with representative Heath
um you know I understand Turnpike funds
stay with the turnpike but perhaps arpa
funds what can go into the turnpike what
um
I I don't believe there are
um any real restrictions on that um
there are
um
the one restrictions that do come with
the if
um is is it can federalize the thing so
if we take federal funds for example so
federal funds can be used on on the
turnpike system
but
um if you do put federal funds into the
turnpike system depending what section
is that that then
kind of federalizes that that
um that section and
um May potentially have less discretion
on what we can do to operate that an
the um the airport Access Road for
example right there at exit I have to
get the number but um
13 exit 13 which is the the road to the
airport a lot of that infrastructure in
and around there was was built with with
federal funds when the question came up
about moving the Bedford toll plaza
maybe if it goes a t moving it further
south towards Merrimack or or Nashua
there are no plans to do that it was
just a question that was asked some time
ago one of the things that we ran into
was because we used federal funds on
that portion of the of the turnpike we
did not have the latitude of of
um of uh moving the toll plaza and and
um
you know tolling a section of of
road that uh federal funds were used on
so that that has been our historic
restriction on using federal funds on
the turnpike system is that it comes
since you brought up the the airport
um who this decided
the best way to get from you know point
a to the airport I mean you go off Brown
and you take a left and you're like
there and one time I followed the signs
to the airport from you know the highway
signs and I was like 30 minutes longer
to go all the way around and back and
you talk about spaghetti
um who where did that design come from
and did you take away the you know did
you take away the information about
getting off at Brown and just taking a
left and going right into the airport
because of potential congestion as the
airport increases
foreign
that was a long that was a long project
uh uh decades ago they got that done had
many Alternatives but the primary reason
was uh for the way it's routed now was
to relieve um Brown ad for the traffic
and the growth of the Manchester Airport
at that time particularly
some of us remember about eight years
ago when the turnpike was doing well and
they spent eight million dollars or
something like that to the dot to buy
the last piece of road
to get to Maine you went from the
Massachusetts border and it stopped
somewhere before it got to the main
border and so they bought that last
eight miles of Road
for about I don't know 20 million 30
million dollars something like that and
uh you know it was a way to transfer
more than that I think it was like a
hundred and something I think it went on
for three or four years the money was
transferred over three or four but that
was a way to to transfer money from
Turnpike to
to Highway fun
but you run out of those options of
doing things like that made sense
because it was
straight it was it was the whole way
across the state so
yeah and that was um I I know
when that was set up it was intended to
be a longer term Revenue stream of
10 10 to 15 years and
again to balance the highway fund it got
it got it got paid out much much quicker
it's reflected in that chart I had
pointed and I think it's still your your
most profitable
Turnpike it takes even though it's not
the most mileage it brings in more money
than the other oh yes yeah the Hampton
so I just wanted to just close uh if
we'll come back and go line by line any
any very any specific detailed questions
I didn't want to leave you with the
impression that we aren't
um satisfied with the with the budget
um
we certainly are
um most all of the um
um programs and things we didn't
experience any Cuts thing things were
covered we had some identified
additional needs
um that that we pointed out but but you
know we can live with this budget with
the realization that if there are
inflationary impacts and things like
that you know we will be back to fiscal
and others to
um
um to to address them
so with that I did that that's what I
just offered in closing that uh it you
know we are satisfied with with the with
the budget and uh look forward to
working with division two through the
rest of the process okay well thank you
foreign
s out there today I think we got some
snow coming tomorrow night and stuff but
yeah
well thank you very much thank you all
appreciate it
okay
anybody else have anything for this work
session
okay
wow
[Music]